-Our next guest
is a Golden Globe, DGA,
and BAFTA Award-winning director
for her film "Nomadland,"
which is currently
in theaters and on Hulu
and has been nominated
for six Academy Awards.
Let's take a look.
-The way I see it
is that the Titanic is sinking
and, uh, economic times
are changing.
And so my goal is to get the
life boats out
and get as many people
into the life boats as I can
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Nah, there's plenty.
-Oh, yeah, we've got plenty,
jump and shout.
-Let you know, huh?
-What's that?
-It's vegan.
-This is vegan?
-No, I'm a -- I'm a carnivore.
-Good?
-Okay.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, okay. Thank you, though
Looks good.
-Another carnivore?
-She's a carnivore.
-Okay.
-Please welcome to the sho
Chloe Zhao.
How are you, Chloe?
-I'm good. Hi.
Thanks for having me.
-Oh, my God.
I'm delighted to have you.
Congratulations both on
the awards you've been gathering
as we go into Oscar season
as well as your six nominations.
I imagine it was very surrea
for the film to receive
that many nominations.
Are you someone
who enjoys that on the day
when you get the news?
-I'm usually asleep when
those announcements happens.
and then -- No, I am happy
And when we set up to make
a film like this the way we did,
this is not what we expect. No
-I've also read
you talking about the fact
that it's extra special
because you have so many friends
amongst those who've been
nominated this year.
-Yeah. This year feels lik
it's going to be
a really, really intimate
affair, which is exciting.
There are people that are my
co-workers
who were producers
on my previous films,
and classmates who I --
We know each other way too well.
[ Laughs ]
And -- And also, people
I admire for a long time,
people that influence
my career so much.
And so having all these people
in a room together
is gonna be great.
-Your part --
-And be with people.
And be with people.
-Yeah, to be with people.
It doesn't even matter
who they are.
You don't even
have to respect them.
If they're people,
it's a win right now.
-Exactly. A person! Hug me
Oh, no. We can't do, either.
No, not yet.
-So, this is also very nice.
Your partner was the
cinematographer on this film
and, so, you're living
under one roof.
He also received his first
Academy Award nomination
and very deservedly so.
This film is beautifully shot.
That must have saved any
awkwardness
if you were the only one
who got the call that morning.
-You know, that's
what pets are for.
You know, you can always
call the dogs over
to avoid awkwardness.
No, we're definitely
both super happy,
you know, more happy the other
person is nominated than us.
Out of love, yes, but mostly out
of avoiding awkwardness, yes
-This is a --
For those who don't know,
this is a beautiful film
about people,
nomads, for, you know,
lack of a better term,
who don't have
a permanent address.
And they're sort of findin
their way across the country
This was based on a book.
I'm wondering how you
first got introduced
to this piece of nonfictio
and how it --
sort of what the journey was
to making it into a film.
-Well, Frances McDormand,
who's also one of the producer
on the film,
she and her producing partner,
Peter Spears,
optioned the book, "Nomadland"
by Jessica Bruder.
And Fran was in Toronto when she
was supposed to be doing press
She sneaked away
and watched a movie
and that was "The Rider,"
my -- my second film.
And I think as a producer, she
sort of put two things together.
She goes, oh, maybe there's
different way
of making this film
than the one she's used to
And she called me up.
-One of the things that's very
different about this film
is it's no surprise to anyon
whose seen Frances McDormand
that she's wonderful in it
but you also cast
a lot of non-actors,
and it brings a real
authenticity to the film.
Is that something you knew
from the very beginning
that you would use people --
many people who appeared
in the book that are playing
slightly fictionalized
versions of themselves?
-Mm-hmm. Yeah. That's what
excites me about this film
It's when I read the book
and then it was from Fran,
and I thought, "Can these
two things come together?"
You know, to have these really
interesting characters,
that it's going to provide a
kind of undeniable authenticit
that you don't usually
see onscreen.
And yet they're united togethe
by a very strong performance
with an emotional arc
that is going to be able
to piece them together,
like by Frances McDormand.
That was really
the identity of the film,
and I got excited about that
before anything else.
-Do you find yourself
directing differently
when you're dealing with
accomplished actors on one han
and then people who haven'
done film work in the past
Or do you speak to everybody
the same way?
I mean, how do you get those
performances out of people
who are, you know, ultimatel
you probably just want the
to be true to who they are
-Yeah, I have to -- The most
important part is writing,
writing for
non-professional actors,
because you want them
to be a version of themselves,
and that's why you cast them
And you don't want them
to be anything else.
But writing them and --
So, by the time I got to set
the stuff they're going to say
are mostly things
they already said to me.
And then they can take me
to places that's going
to be surprising.
But with Fran, she would say
that I probably pay
a lot more attention
to the non-professional actors
than I do her.
I usually film her at the end.
So poor Fran would get like,
you know, couple -- two takes.
Not that she needed more.
And then sometimes
she would give me
like four or five
different reactions
just in case in the edit,
that I would want
to do things differently,
because the non-professional
actors often surprised us
with things we didn't expect
-As I've mentioned multipl
times now, it's a beautiful film
that shows a lot of places
in this country
that I'm sure many people
have never been.
Are there places that you went
in the making of this movi
that you want to return to
-Definitely Quartzsite, Arizona.
If you haven't been -- You know,
I think because
it's so hot in the summer,
so then every year around winter
time is when all the nomadic -
People who live a nomadic
lifestyle over the country
gather together.
It's quite a sight.
I love that place.
-I'd like to finish by askin
about another project you're
working on that's so exciting.
You're also a member
of the Marvel Universe now
and have "The Eternals"
coming out later this year
Is comics something
that you were a fan of?
Were you aware of that world
before you got involved?
-I grew up with manga more tha
the American comic books.
It was the Japanese manga.
But I have been a fan of the MCU
for about a decade now
because of the movies.
And I think --
I don't know if that
helped my pitch or not,
but I think they could tel
that I was a fan.
-Well, it's a really
exciting marriage
to think of you helming
something like that,
and I can't wait for that.
Best of luck at the Oscars
and thank you so much
for the beautiful film.
-Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
-Of course.
"Nomadland" is currently
in theaters and on Hulu.